المخيم كما ذكرت مستهدف منذ فتره يطلق
عليه اسرائيليا عش الدبابير ولكن كيف بدا
السياق الزمني لهذه العملي
معركه سيف القدس هو يتوعد مخيم جنين لان
المقاومه هناك قالت بشكل واضح وعرض
مؤتمرات صحفيه
ومنذ ذلك الوقت حتى اليوم تستمر
لكن الى القلب المخيم لم يتمكن من الوصول
اطلاقا انطوان الفتره الماضيه لذلك الان
ويركز على استخدام الوحدات المشهد بدا انه
استغل ساعات الصباح طبعا زعلانين ان
المقاومين والمقاتلين يسهرون طوال الليل
في غزوه والاردات والمتابعه التحركات
الاسرائيليه بالمناسبه
لذلك الاحتلال فتره الصباح وهو يعتقد ان
المقاولون يذهبون الى النوم
الخاصه التي استخدمت 4 مركبات فلسطينيات
كانت تتضمن
او مجموعه من الوحدات خاصه
المقاومينشتهم مما ادى الى تحول العمليه
انقلبت على الاحتلال واصبحت معركه عنيفه
جدا لا زالت مستمره حتى هذه اللحظه
بالمناسبه الوحدات الخاصه او الاحتلال لا
يحاول الرسول الى مخيم جنين الا بالتوفيق
من الوحدات الخاصه كنا قوات كبيره من
الجيش يذكر ان مخيم جنين خاض في عام 2002
2002 في ميسان معركه عنيفه كل العالم
يتحدث ما زال عنها انتهاء